GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK TO
SUB. COMMITTEE FOR A STATE
ADMINISTRATION.
TODAY WILL DISCUSS THE BUDGETS
OF DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL.
WE PARTNER BUSINESS OVERSIGHT.
APARTMENTS HUMAN RESOURCES AND
STATE PERSONNEL BOARD.
YOU KNOW HOW QUORUM WILL START
OFFICE COMMITTEE.
RIVERSIDE A MUSICIAN NUMBER ONE.
ORIGINAL SERVICES CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS SECOND REGION.
HI UP MY NAME IS JASON KENNEY I
AM THE STSCI ACTING THE
PROJECTOR FOR THE REAL ESTATE
SERVICES DIVISION FOR TGS.
WE HAVE FOUR PROJECTS BEFORE
TODAY THE IT WAS P. PRINT PLANT
DEMOLITION THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
NEW RICHARD BILL OF OUR COMPLEX.
OF THE RENOVATION A GREATLY
BATES IN BUILDING AND THE
RENOVATION OF THE JUST THE UNDER
BUILDING.
SINCE THESE ITEMS ARE TOGETHER
ON THE AGENDA I'LL RUN THROUGH
THEM.
QUICKLY ONE OF THE TIME.
A THE IT WAS P. PRINT BUT
NUMBERLESS XIN.
WE ARE REQUESTING INHABITING
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE WORKING
DRAWING PHASE FOR THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST OF SIXTEEN MILLION.
BLASTER LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED.
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC PLANS AND US
TODAY WE ARE ON SCHEDULE AND ON
BUDGET. OF THIS SITE HAS BEEN
TARGETED FOR DUMP LA DOT
DEVELOPMENT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETIES AND THE CURRENT TENANTS
IS A RELOCATING TO US SMALLER
MORE EFFICIENTLY SPACE.
THIS DEMOLITION ALLOW THE SITE
TO BE USED FOR FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT AND AVOID WARM SHUT
DOWN COSTS.
THE SECOND PROJECT IS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW RICHARD
BOULEVARD COMPLEX.
FOR THIS PROJECT WE ARE SEEKING
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS POOR
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA FOR
DEVELOPMENT UPSET COMPLEX THE
TOTAL PROJECT COST IS ESTIMATED
AT JUST OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS COMPLEX LOW YOU FOR SIX
WEEK NICHOLAS DELTA QUEEN.
COOPER HERE ALAN CARRERO. CHOI.
PROCEED ABSOLUTELY.
UP TO THIS COMPLEX IS NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS THE OVERALL
SACRAMENTO OFFICE BASED
EFFICIENCY OF THE DEFIED IN THE
TWENTY A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
SACRAMENTO REGION OFFICE
PLANNING STUDY AND THEN UPDATE
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO LEGISLATORS
REQUEST.
I IT'S ALSO PART OF OUR
SACRAMENTO SEQUENCING PLAN TO DO
ADDRESSED EFFICIENT SPACE IN THE
CITY.
THE PROJECT WILL CONSIST OF OF
A CONCEPTUALLY TWENTY NINE STORY
TOWER THE HOUSE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICE HOUSING AGENCY
IN DEPARTMENTS. OF THREE FIVE
STORY BUILDINGS TO HOUSE THE
DEPARTMENT TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION.
A PARKING GARAGE INSISTED
SURFACE PARKING.
I'M.
THE NEXT PROJECT BEFORE YOU IS
THE RENOVATION OF THE GREGORY
BATESON BUILDING SO THE GRANT
WE'RE REQUESTING FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA TO RENOVATE SAID
BUILDING. TOTAL PROJECT COST
WOULD BE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
MILLION. OF THAT BUILDING.
WAS CONSTRUCTED IN THE LATE
EIGHTIES SEVENTIES EARLY
EIGHTIES.
IT WAS THAT THE STATE'S OUR
FIRST REAL ATTEMPT AT A GREEN
BUILDING.
AND IT IS HISTORICAL AYE IT.
DOES RANK FOURTH OVERALL IN THE
WORST BUILDING.
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR SECOND
PORTFOLIO AND VISITING IN AND IS
IN NEED OF SIGNIFICANT
RENOVATION. OF THAT WOULD
INCLUDE WORK ON ALL MAJOR
BUILDING SYSTEMS ADJUSTING FIRE
LIFE SAFETY ISSUES INCLUDING
FIRE SPRINKLER INSTALLATION.
THE THE BUILDING HAS A
SIGNIFICANT WATER INTRUSION
ISSUES HOUSES MATERIALS.
IT IS CERTAIN THE ADA
COMPLIANCE.
NEEDS A NEW OUR CONTROL
LIGHTING SYSTEM SECURITY
IMPROVEMENTS LETTER.
AND THAT BUILDING WILL
ULTIMATELY BE.
TENDED BY THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE NOT GOING
IN THE.
NEW RESOURCES BUILDING THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
CREDIT COLOR OF A CAMPUS
COMPLEX FOR THOSE TWO
DEPARTMENTS.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE THE
RENOVATION THE JUST A HUNDRED
BUILDING.
.
WE'RE REQUESTING SIX POINT THREE
MILLION IN PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
FOR THAT PROJECT TOTAL PROJECT
COSTS ARE EXPECTED TO BE. IT
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE UNDER BUILDING WAS
CONSTRUCTED NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
IS A HISTORICAL LANDMARK AND AS
OUR FIFTH OVERALL WAS BUILDING
OUR PORTFOLIO. A IT IS ALSO IN
NEED OF COMPREHENSIVE
RENOVATIONS AND SIGNIFICANTLY
AND NUMBER FIRE LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES.
INSULATION A FIRE SPRINKLERS.
ADDITION OF TWO NEW US FIVE
STORY STAIRS FOR EXITING
MULTIPLE SMOKE VERY AND FIRE
STOPPING EFFICIENCIES REPLACING
ALL MAJOR BUILDING SYSTEMS.
THE IT ALSO HAS A WATER
INTRUSION ISSUE HAS MATA IS NOT
YOU COMPLIANCE IT'S EITHER. A
ONCE RENOVATED THIS BUILDING
WILL HOUSE THE STATE CONTRIBUTED
TREASURER'S OFFICE CONSOLIDATED
OUR AND WOULD ALSO AVOID
WATCHING ONE SHUT DOWN BECAUSE
LIKE THE BATES AND BUILDING
WOULD.
THANK YOU.
LL.
COMING CRISTINA LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE
PROPOSALS AYE WITH REGARD TO THE
PRINTING PLANT DEMOLITION AND
I'M WE DON'T RAISE ANY ISSUES
WITH THAT WE DO THINK IT MAKES
SENSE TO DEMOLISH THAT BUILDING.
AND GIVEN THAT REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THAT SITES USED FOR.
IT THAT PUBLIC DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO HAVE THAT EXISTING
BUILDING ON THAT SITE.
HOWEVER WE ARE RECOMMENDING
REJECTING REJECTING.
THE FUNDING FOR THE RICHARDS
BOULEVARD PROJECT.
THAT'S BECAUSE BASED ON OUR
ANALYSIS IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT
THAT PROJECT IS A COST EFFECTIVE
WAY FOR THE STATE TO MEET ITS
BUILDING MEANS. I'M SO
SPECIFICALLY WE ESTIMATED THE
COST OF THE COSTS OF BUILDING ON
AND MAINTAINING AN OPERATING
THAT BUILDING AND COMPARED THEM
TO THE COSTS.
BECAUSE SAVINGS THAT WOULD.
RECRUITED THE STATE FROM NOT
HAVING TO LEASE.
THE EXISTING SPACE THAT THOSE
PATENT PERMITS ARE AND.
ALLAH WHEN WE COMPARED THOSE AND
LOOK AT HOW LONG IT WOULD TAKE
FOR THIS STATE WITH COULD BREAK
EVEN. ON THE WE GOT A NUMBER
THAT WAS OVER EIGHTY YEARS AND
THAT'S RELATIVELY LONG WE THINK
THAT'S LONGER THAN THAT. LIKE
WE.
WIFE OF THE BUILDING AYE WE
WOULD KNOW DID YES HAD A LOWER
NUMBER.
THEIR FEW DIFFERENCES IN OUR
CALCULATIONS.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT OUR
NUMBERS MORE APPROPRIATE THE
COUPLE THE BIGGEST ONES ONE WAS.
THAT THEY DIDN'T DISCOUNT OF THE
CASH FLOWS AND WE THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO DO DOING
KNOWLEDGE THAT MONEY TODAY IS
WORTH MORE THAN THAN MONEY IN
THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE OF INFLATION AND OTHER
FACTORS.
ALSO THERE SOME OTHER
ASSUMPTIONS LIKE OUT WE THOUGHT
THAT THE ASSUMES THAT THE. A
RATE OF INCREASE IN MANAGEMENT.
AND OPERATIONS COSTS WAS TOO
LOW THEY ASSUMED OF LESS THAN
ONE PERCENT INCREASE YOUR PRE
YEAR THERE WAS A POINT FIVE
PERCENT SAID WE ADJUSTED THOSE.
THOSE ASSUMPTIONS WE GOT OVER
EIGHTY YEARS WE THINK THAT THAT.
SUGGEST THAT IT'S NOT A VERY A
COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO MEET THE
STATE'S BUILDING NEEDS.
I'M SO NOTABLY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE NOT APPROVE THE
FUNDING AND INSTEAD DIRECTS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COME FORWARD
WITH AN ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL. ON
THAT COULD BE A DIFFERENT
BUILDING ON THE SITE IT COULD BE
SELLING THE SITE. ON THERE
POTENTIALLY EVEREADY OF OPTIONS
AYE WE'RE ALSO RECOMMENDING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
SEQUENCING PLAN SO. BOTH THE
RICHARDS BOULEVARD PROJECT AS
WELL AS THE TWO RENOVATION
PROJECT THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT
THEY'RE ALL PART. OF THIS
SACRAMENTO SERVE STRATEGY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS AND. DIRT
THAT STRATEGY IS.
PRETTY ARE INTERCONNECTED AND
LINKED SO MANY CASES OTHER
SERVICE SEQUENCE OF RENOVATION
YOUR NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
RENOVATION PROJECTS.
I'M SO WE THINK IT'S WORTH
HAVING MORE INFORMATION ON. WHAT
ALTERNATIVES MIGHT BE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN SO FOR
EXAMPLE HE DIDN'T MOVE FORWARD
WITH RICHARD BOULEVARD PROJECT?
ON WHAT ARE SOME OTHER OPTIONS
THAT YOU COULD PURSUE. I'M
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE PARTIES
LEGISLATURE HOUSE.
AND THEN FINALLY. OVER
RECOMMENDING ABOUT IT YES REPORT
ON THE RENOVATION PROJECT THAT
YOU HEARD THEIR TO PROPOSED
RENOVATIONS PROJECTS THAT BATES
AND PROJECT.
I AND I'M ARE PROJECTS WE DO
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO REPAIR
AND RENOVATE THOSE TWO
BUILDINGS.
ARE THEY BOTH HAVE VERY
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
BASIN SOLELY CONDITION
ASSESSMENT THAT WERE CONDUCTED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THEY WERE
BOTH ASSESSED TO BE AN IMPORT
CONDITION AND HAVE. I'M SOME
SUBSTANTIAL ISSUES SO WE THINK
IT'S CERTAINLY REASONABLE. BUT
TO PURSUE SOME RENOVATIONS OF
THOSE PROJECTS.
WE DO KNOW THAT WE THINK THAT
THE PRESSURE COSTS APPEAR TO BE.
UP PRETTY HIGH THEIR HIGHER THAN
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS BUILDING
HUNDRED HAITIANS THAT THE STATE
HAS.
HAS ENGAGED IN INCLUDING THE
LIBRARIAN COURTS AS WELL AS
OFFICE BUILDING EIGHT AND NINE
AND THOSE WERE. A COUPLE OF THE
MOST RECENT OF A SIGNIFICANT
INNOVATONS THE STATE'S
UNDERTAKEN.
I'M SO I THINK IT'S WORTH HAVING
ADMINISTRATION REPORT ON THE
REASONS FOR THE COSTS AS WELL
AS.
CAN REPORT ON SOME POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVE SCOPES THAT MIGHT BE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE.
FINANCE.
SILICON.
THE FEDERAL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
PRESENTATION AND FOR THE
ANALYSIS I GUESS.
IT WILL AND I'D LIKE TO GET A
SENSE FOR.
IT THE GREAT COUNTY WHERE.
DEED YES SEIZE THE STATE GOING
IN REGARDS TO BUILDINGS UP AND
RENTAL SPACE BECAUSE.
BACK.
A FEW YEARS AGO THAT I THE.
WE HAD SIGNIFICANT DOWNTURN IN
THE ECONOMY WE HAD A REDUCTION
OR AN A CONTRACTION OF THE
WORKFORCE BECAUSE.
WE WERE FILLING VACANCIES AND
SO WE HAD A LOT OF BACON STATE
SPACE ARE WERE TO PUT IT MORE
SPECIFICALLY WEEK WE HAD A LOT
OF VACANCIES IN STATE OWNED
BUILDINGS AND SO WE WERE TRYING
TO GET.
THAT DEPARTMENTS ADDED MOVED
OUT INTO OUR PRIVATE RENTAL
SPACE BACK INTO THE BUILDINGS.
BUT THERE WERE ISSUES WITH.
ADA COMPLIANCE AND ALL THAT
KIND STEP IN SO THERE WAS THIS
THIS CHALLENGE BETWEEN.
HOW DO WE UTILIZE?
OUR OUR SPACE WELL SO SO NUMBER
ONE IS THE STATE DID NOT DO A
VERY GOOD JOB OF.
AT KEEPING UP WITH ME IN ITS
AND THAT I THINK YOU FIND THAT
OVERALL IS THE CASE IN IN
GOVERNMENT IS THAT WHEN TIMES
GET TOUGH.
WE TRY TO KEEP. EXISTING
SERVICES GOING AND SO WE. WE
DELETE THAT MAINTENANCE.
AND AND SO THEN WHEN WE FINALLY
DO TURN THE ECONOMY AROUND WE
START TO TRY TO FIX THE MAIN AND
SENATE'S COST US A LOT MORE IT'S
NOT VERY COST EFFECTIVE AND SO.
SO.
THERE THAT THAT QUESTION BECAME
DO WE UPGRADE THE STATE SPACE
AND.
HAVE STATE DEPARTMENT STAY IN
THAT SPACE OR DO WE.
CELL. AND LET SOMEONE ELSE
WORRY ABOUT THAT UPKEEP AND
MAINTENANCE AND.
WE RENT AND SO I AM TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING AS I LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR ON REQUEST BECAUSE.
THE RENOVATIONS ARE EXPENSIVE
AND.
.
YEAH BUT BUT THEY'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT STATE BUILDINGS AND
AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE WE
SHOULD KEEP THEM.
IT AND I THINK THE SEQUENCING
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS
YOU VACATE. THE BUILDING YOU
GOTTA PUT PEOPLE SOMEPLACE AND
THEN.
HAVE HAVE THEM CLOSE ENOUGH SO
THAT YOU CAN THEN BRING THEM
BACK WITHOUT IT BEING AT THE
CHALLENGE AND SO I WAS TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF.
OF WHAT THE THE SEQUENCE WAS
GOING TO BE AROUND THE STATE AND
THE.
.
THAT THAT THEIR PRINTING PLANT
LOCATION SITES SEEM TO BE PRETTY
IMPORTANT TO THAT WHOLE
DISCUSSION IN AND OUT. BUT.
BUT IT DIDN'T HAVE A.
THAT THEIR REQUEST
WAS FOR.
WORKING DRAWINGS AND I ASSUME
THAT WAS IN PREPARATION OF THE
BID PROCESS.
BUT IT WASN'T REALLY CLEAR TO
ME IF THAT IS BECAUSE THE OTHER
ONES TALK ABOUT DESIGN BUILD
KNOWS THAT THE PREFERRED
STRATEGY AND SO IF IT IF YOU
COULD JUST I'M NOT. I'M NOT SURE
I'VE GOT A SPECIFIC QUESTION
OTHER THAN I'M REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW
THESE ALL WORK TOGETHER AND THE
COSTS
FOR?
RENOVATION DO SEEM VERY HIGH
GIVEN THAT THE COURTS WAS WITH
IT WAS X. A MEAN THAT REALLY IS
A A PRIMO CHAPEL OF OF DOING THE
HIGHEST QUALITY I THINK. A
RENOVATION THAT YOU CAN GET I
THINK IT LOOKS BEAUTIFUL
COMPARED TO WHEN IT LOOKED LIKE
BEFORE. ON SO COULD IF YOU COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEM
SEQUENCING WAITRESS THOUGHT IS.
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
PERSPECTIVE ON.
UPGRADING OUR OUR ON.
OUR OWN EXISTING BUILDINGS AND
UTILIZE A MINUTE ASSUMING WHAT
WERE THEIR GOAL IS TO UTILIZE
OUR OWN. UP RESOURCES AND NOT
HAVE TO RENT OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE BUT PRINT UNLESS WE REALLY
HAVE TO SO I GUESS THAT'S A. ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS SURE THAT'S A
THAT'S A LOTTA TO BITE OFF I
WILL TRY TO BE AND CONCISE.
ALSO ULTIMATELY YEAH WE WE HAVE
DOING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN IS
HAVING A LOOK AT ALL THE DEVIOUS
OWNED OFFICE BUILDINGS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA FOLLOWED BY THE
REST OF THAT THE STATE.
THOSE BUILDINGS WERE THEN
RANKED IN TERMS OF.
THE SEVERITY OF THE
DEFICIENCIES.
WE THEN DEVELOPED A SEQUENCING
PLAN PRINCIPLES THAT.
SO WE WERE LOOKING AT NOT JUST
WHICH BUILDINGS ARE WERE THE
MOST IN NEED OF SPACE BUT IF
WE'RE GOING TO RENOVATE ONE
KNOWING THAT THERE'S REALLY NOT
ANY LEASABLE SPACE IN SACRAMENTO
OF ANY SIGNIFICANCE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BUILD A NEW
BUILDING.
IN ADDITION OF THAT YOUR POINT
ABOUT SORT OF THE THE THE
EXPANDING CONTRACTING NATURE OF
OF.
THE STATE WORKFORCE ON A LONG
ENOUGH TIMELINE IT TENDS TO
KEEPING PACE WITH POPULATION
GROWTH.
AND SO WHAT WE SEE OVER TIME IS
THE NEED FOR EVER INCREASING
ADDITIONAL OFFICE SPACE AND YOU
SEE THAT I THINK EVEN WITH PHIL
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS.
THAT SPURRED ADDITIONAL SPACE
REQUESTS INTO THE GOVERNMENT
TENDS TO DO THAT.
AND SO THIS DO WILL NEED
ADDITIONAL SPACE AS WELL AS THE
FACT THAT WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
LANDLOCKED IN SACRAMENTO TO
BEGIN WITH IT.
INITIATED US INTO BUILDING THE
NEW NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
BUILDING IN THE TWIN TURBO THREE
BILLION WHICH IS AUTHORIZED AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
THOSE TWO PROJECTS AS THEY ARE
BUILT THEN ALLOW US TO MOVE
TENANTS FROM DEFICIENT SPACE
INTO NEW SPACE.
WE ARE AGAIN COME LOOKING AT
THE LARGEST SPACE.
AS WELL AS WHAT KIND OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES WE CAN
GAIN A THROUGH THE PROCESS SO.
RIGHT NOW THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY HAS.
TO GET A TOTAL OF SEVEN
APARTMENTS PLUS THE AGENCY
ITSELF A BIG ON THE NATURAL
RESOURCES NEW DATA RESOURCES
BUILDING.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO CONSOLIDATE
THE WAY THEY HAD BEEN ABLE
CONSULTANT BEFORE. ON THE
PROFITING ULTRA BUILDING WILL
TAKE THE TENANTS IN THE BATES
AND BUILDING AND AND PUT THEM IN
NEW SPACE ALLOWING US TO
RENOVATE THE BATES AND.
SO IT THIS SEQUENCING PLAN
ALLOWS US TO CREATE SPACE MOVE
PEOPLE INTO THOSE SPACES AND THE
RENOVATE BEHIND.
ULTIMATELY ARE.
TICKETING PLAN PRINCIPLES.
DO PREFER TO OWN IN AREAS OF OF.
HI LISA ABOUT THAT HIGHWAYS
COSTS AND RIGHT NOW IN
SACRAMENTO IS PRICKLY THE
DOWNTOWN CORE IT IS. VERY
EXPENSIVE TO LEASE SPACE.
SO THE THE GOAL IS OLD LIVING
FROM INTEREST IN PERSPECTIVE TO.
CONTINUE THIS.
PROCESS OF UPDATING ARE
DEFICIENT SPACE
I'M RICHARDS BOULEVARDS USE YOUR
POINT ABOUT THE WORKING DRAWINGS
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE THE STATE.
PRINT PLANT THAT'S ON THAT SITE.
THE WORKING DRAWINGS REQUEST IS
RELATED TO THE DEMOLITION OF
THAT PROJECT ONCE WE DEMOLISH
THAT PROJECT IT AVOIDS HAVING TO
PAY ONE SHUT DOWN BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS US TO CHEAT UP FOR
DEVELOPMENT OR TALENT OR
WHATEVER ELSE HAPPENS. HOWEVER
OUR PLANET PRESENT IS TO WITH
RICHARD BELOW PROJECT TO BUILD A
NEW CAMPUS COMPLEX ON THAT SITE.
DOING THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
RENOVATE FOR FIFTY AND STREET
WHICH IS THE BILL.
BUILDING.
AND THEN ALLOW TO CONSOLIDATE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY INTO THAT NOT BUILDING.
SO WE HAVE THIS THAT THE TENURE
SEQUENCING PLAN IS A YOU KNOW
COMPREHENSIVE COULD OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITIZES.
RENOVATION NEW CONSTRUCTION TO
ENABLE US TO RENOVATIONS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
IF WE WERE TO TAKE SAY THE.
THE THE THREE HUNDRED AND I
ALSO HAVE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
THAT'S IN THE BATES AND BUILDING
THERE'S NOT THAT KIND SPACE IN
SACRAMENTO WOULD BE DIVIDED THE
DEPARTMENT UP INTO FIVE OR SIX
DIFFERENT LEASES THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA.
SO WEAK INCOME HOW TO BE SINGLE
IT'S THE WAY IT IS.
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF
VARIABLES YOU HAVE THE. THE
CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULES YOU HAVE
THE.
EXISTING SQUARE FOOTAGE IN
BUILDINGS YOU HAVE.
THAT THE LEASE SPACE IN
SACRAMENTO WHEN LEASES EXPIRE
WHO MY CONSOLIDATORS UP THERE'S
A DOZEN OR SO VARIABLES THAT
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE KIND OF
CRAFT THE PLANE AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
AND YOUR QUESTION THAT LISA HIGH
LEVEL YES I THINK THAT I GUESS
THAT THE PRINCIPLES AYE AND
MONEY HERE IS ONE THAT THAT WE
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE ARTS OUR OWN.
STATE OWNS YES THAT ARE
DEPARTMENTS I TO BE IN STATE ON
SPACE NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO THAT
THE EXISTING.
OUR.
ARE ADEQUATE TO DO A
REORGANIZATION.
IT AS YOU GO THROUGH AND
RENOVATE.
THAT THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING
THE X. AT INCREASE POTENTIAL
INCREASE IN. IN THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS BASED ON POPULATION
BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN A GOOD
MEASURE OF.
OF.
OF GROWTH AND THAT FOR THAT
ULTIMATELY THE.
THIS SPACE THAT'S CREATED
HOPEFULLY IS GOING TO BE OUT
DESIGNED ACCORDING TO NEW
STANDARDS.
IN TERMS OF HOW WORK SPACES
DESIGN BUT ALSO WITH COST
EFFICIENCIES IN MIND THAT WHERE.
THAT WHAT WE END UP FIXING OR
DEVELOPING IS NOT GOING TO BE.
SO MUCH OVER THE MARKET THAT IT
DOESN'T IT WOULDN'T HAVE MADE
SENSE TO DO IT BUT WE JUST
DECIDED WE NEED TO IT ANYWAY SO
THAT I GUESS IT THAT THE. PEOPLE
YOU IT SOUNDED TO ME LIKE YOU
WERE.
AT PRETTY MUCH STATING THAT AND
THAT'S.
KIND OF WHAT I WHAT THAT'S THE
FRAMEWORK I WANTED TO HEAR SO
PERFECT.
I PICKED PRESHEAF THAT THING
SURE IT WILL STILL GET THE
NUMBER OF LEASES WE HAVE
DOWNTOWN AND THEN THAT A DOLLAR
AMOUNT.
LA I TUCK MY HEAD I KNOW HOW
MANY.
WE HAVE ACROSS ALL THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS.
.
I HAVE TO COME BACK WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT SHOULD BE
CURIOUS WHAT THAT IS AND WITH
LONG TERM PLANS ARE FOR THOSE
WHO.
AND THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL JUST
FOR DOWN THE ROAD SURE YEAH WE
CAN WE CAN OFFICE PROCEEDINGS
BUT YEAH THAT BE GREAT THANK
YOU.
OPEN UP TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
IN WHICH IS BECAUSE ITEM
I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
A RECOMMENDATION ALL THIS ITEM
OPEN SLOWLY OPEN.
NEXT ON THE SHE NUMBER TWO.
IF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSESSMENT
FACILITY DEVELOPMENT.
AFTERNOON CHAIR COOPER.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CABALLERO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME INTEREST
APPLES DEPUTY DIRECTOR FURNITURE
SERVICES THE TGS.
FOR ITEM TO EVE YES SEE THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION OF FIFTEEN POINT
SIX MILLION AND THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. POINT NINETEEN FISCAL
YEAR AND ONE PERMANENT POSITION
TO CONTINUE THE INSTALLATION OF
PBS.
FACILITIES AND STATE FACILITIES
OF THAT AMOUNT SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION BE TRANSFERRED FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
AS WELL SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION FROM THE SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND THE FUNDING WAS A
POOR PERFORMING APPROXIMATELY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED ASSESSMENTS
INSTALLING TWELVE HUNDRED
CHARTERS THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT ACTION PLAN AND MORE RECENT
EXPANDED THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER
REQUIRES DDS OVERSEE PLANS TO
MAKE ANY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AVAILABLE AND WORKPLACE PARKING
SPACES AT STATE FACILITIES.
WITH ME IS NANCY AND OUR DEPUTY
RECTOR SUSTAINABILITY WHO'S HERE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
LL.
I SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER CONSIDER
POTENTIAL USING OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES FOR THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FIND OR
THEY'LL TURN EVAN RENEWABLE FUEL
AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FUNDS.
I'M IN ORDER TO.
FACILITATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION OF THOSE FUNDING
SOURCES RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION AND TO REPORT ON.
Y.. WHY DIDN'T USE THOSE
SOURCES AND WHETHER THOSE
SOURCES MIGHT BE AVAILABLE?
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THEIR COUPLE
REASONS FOR THIS RECOMMENDATION
FIRST.
SO THIS PROPOSAL THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR WE'VE HAD FUNDING
FOR BASICALLY THIS.
GENERAL PURPOSE IN LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS AND ALSO.
WE EXPECT THAT THEY'LL BE
FUTURE PROPOSALS.
IN THIS AREA BECAUSE THAT GOALS
ARE REALLY.
MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN
WE'RE GONNA REACH THIS YEAR IN
TERMS OF BOTH WE. A SEVEN
PRODUCTION AS WELL AS WORKPLACE
STATIONS FOR OR I STAFF THAT
WORK FOR THE STATE.
SO IN TOTAL WE EXPECT THAT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH BUILDING
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD.
LIKELY EXCEED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS SO
THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL COSTS.
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES FOR SEVEN PRODUCTION OR
IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR. OTHER
GOVERNORS KEVIN TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN ALLOCATES ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DISCRETIONARY AND YOUR F.
REVENUE.
HOWEVER VERY SICK ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING INCENTIVIZING THE
PRIVATE PURCHASE OF ZEV
VEHICLES.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
SPENDING PLAN INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
FROM THE OTHER FUND THEY MENTION
THE ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE
FUEL. AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY
FUND AS WELL AS A FEW OTHER
FUNDS ARE TO SUPPORT PRIVATE AYE
CHARGING STATIONS SO WE THINK
IT'S WORTH CONSIDERING THIS
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THESE PUBLIC
STATIONS AS WELL.
I WE WOULD KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES HAVE SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD.
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO TRY TO SEEK OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES BUT THE SPAWNING
SOURCES THAT WE. ARE MENTIONED
THERE WOULD ONLY BE AVAILABLE
LIKELY THE LEGISLATURE MADE A
SPECIFIC APPROPRIATION WITHIN
THE BUDGET. TAKE THAT THANK YOU
FINANCE.
FOR DID YES OUT OF THE DIGEST
PLAN TO BUILD OUT THE EVE VESSEY
WHATEVER IT IS INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'M SORRY CAN YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION HOW DO YOU PLAN TO
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
WHAT'S THE PLAN.
I'M WELL THE STEPS ARE TO FIRST
OF ALL TO GO OUT TO THE ACTUAL
SITES PHYSICALLY AND DO AN
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE THE
VIABILITY OF PLACEMENT BASED ON.
A LOCATION BASED ON COST OF
TRENCHING DISTANCE TO THE
FACILITIES THAT CEDRAS SO ONCE
WE DO AN ASSESSMENT. THEN WE CAN
DETERMINE HOW MANY WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE EACH SITE. BUT THE
PLAN IS TO FOCUS ON THE FLEET
FIRST SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
FLEET VEHICLES THAT AT THIS
POINT.
DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE A
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CHARGING AND
SO OUR PRIORITY IS TO PRIORITIZE
THOSE FIRST AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
THE WORKPLACE CHARGING THAT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE FACILITIES
WOULD ALSO BE. TAKEN CARE OF AT
THE SAME TIME FOR ECONOMIC
REASONS WILL EVERY STATE
BUILDING GET THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOT NECESSARILY SO AGAIN AT
FIRST IT WILL BE FLEET AS A
PRIORITY AND NOT EVERY EVERY
STATE AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT HAS
FLEET ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
FACILITIES OF THOSE WOULD BE THE
FIRST PRIORITY. ON SECOND
PRIORITY WILL BE WHERE THERE IS
A NEED FOR WORKPLACE CHARGING SO
AGAIN WITH THEIRS ONE OR TWO
PARKING SPOTS IS TYPICALLY WOULD
NOT BE ECONOMICAL TO GRASP IT OF
ITS A LARGE FACILITY WITH A LOT
OF WORKPLACE NEEDS THAN THOSE
WOULD BE A PRIORITY. AS A SECOND
PRIORITY AND WHAT IS PROJECTED
COST TO SUPPORT ESCALATION OF
ADDITIONAL FACILITIES.
AND WE'RE STILL WERE WERE NAY
ALL IN OUR SECOND YEAR HONOR
SORRY FIRST YEAR THIS IS THIS
REQUEST IS FOR THE SECOND YEARS
SO. WE'RE STILL YEAH I GETTING
STABLE AS FAR AS ACTUAL COSTS
BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S COSTING
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER CHARGING.
SPOT TO INSTALL AND THAT
INCLUDES ALL OF THE DESIGN AS
WELL AS THE INSTALLATION.
A QUESTIONS FROM THE.
QUESTION BUT IT WAS GOV HERE
YEAH I JUST GOT TO SAY THAT
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT.
IBM.
THE CHARGING STATION ISLAM IS
WHEN YOU.
WHEN YOU START FIGURING IT INTO
THE PRICE A VEHICLE THAT THAT'S.
IT JUST IT'S VERY HIGH BUT BUT
MY QUESTION.
IS.
AS I WAS READING THIS.
I THOUGHT THAT THAT.
THE REPORT AND THE THE ANALYSIS
THAT ALREADY BEEN DONE IN TERMS
OF OF THE LOCATIONS AND.
WHERE SOME OF THE FACILITIES
MICO YOU HAVE A MAP THAT WOULD
SHOW US WHERE THESE WOULD BE
DEPLOYED STATEWIDE?
SO THAT THE PROCESS WE WENT
THROUGH AS WE DID A SURVEY WE
SURVEYED BASICALLY ALL OF THE
STATE AGENCIES TO ASK THEM
EXACTLY HOW MANY SPOTS THEY HAVE
EXACTLY HOW MANY FLEET THEY.
CURRENTLY HAVE STRANDED HOW MANY
FLEET THEY HAVE FOR.
INTENTIONS TO PURCHASE OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS AND SO WE GOT WE
GATHERED ALL OF THAT DATA AND SO
OUR PLAN IS BASED ON THAT DATA.
AS WE'RE GOING OUT EACH OF THE
SITES WERE FINDING A LOT OF
INACCURACIES IN THE DATA SO
WE'RE HAVING TO READJUST BASED
ON WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEN OUT
IN THE FIELD. I DO HAVE A LIST
WITH ME OF THE LOCATIONS THAT WE
STARTED WITH THIS YEAR SO I CAN
SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
IT'S ANALYST'S FORM NOT IN A
MAP BUT I CAN CERTAINLY PUT IT
ON A MAP FOR YOU IF THAT'S THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL I THINK FOR FOR
FOR FUTURE REFERENCE JUST TO
GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT THE WET.
WHEN IT LOOKS LIKE SHARE MY
GUESS ISMOST OF THESE.
FACILITIES WILL BE IN URBAN
CENTERS BECAUSE THAT THOSE ARE
WHERE THE SHORTER THAT'S CORRECT
SIR ARE MADE.
AND SO THAT WOULD BE REAL HOPE
FOR FULL FOR MOST OF US OF I'M A
WANNA BE CAREFUL THAT WE'RE NOT
ENDING UP PURCHASING VEHICLES
THAT THAT ARE NOT GOING TO BE
UTILIZED BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
EITHER AND EFFICIENT TO CHARGE
OVER THERE NOT GETTING CHARGED
THE E. EIGHTY FIVE EXPERIENCES
THAT.
WE PURCHASED VERY AB CARS
VEHICLES THAT WERE MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN THEN.
A. DUAL USE E. EIGHTY FIVE WITH
WITH THAT REGULAR FUEL. AND IT
COST US MORE BUT.
STAFF DID NOT USE THE E. EIGHTY
FIVE BECAUSE IT WAS AN
INCONVENIENT TO GO OUT.
TO THE SITES WHERE YOU COULD
ACTUALLY PURCHASE THAT PRODUCT
AND SO.
IN RURAL AREAS TO BUY AN E.
EIGHTY FIVE VEHICLE WAS A REAL
WASTE OF MONEY. AND I'M I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THIS ALL
WORKS OUT IN AND AND MAKE THE
COMMITMENT TO ACTUALLY USING THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
IN IN THE REGIONS WHERE IT.
POSSIBLE TO DO IT YEAH GET YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN WERE
ABSOLUTELY SENSITIVE TO IT WE
ARE DEFINITELY PRIORITIZING
WHERE THERE'S THE GREATEST USAGE
PATTERNS THAT WE'RE SEEING. THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO MENTION
THOUGH IS THAT IT'S AND THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO
LEVERAGE A LOT OF UTILITY
FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
OFFSET. THE STATE COSTS FOR
THESE.
INFRASTRUCTURE INSTALLMENTS AND
IN PARTICULAR WITH P. JEANNIE
RIGHT NOW WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THEM IN THEIR THAT THEY.
THE PROGRAM THEY ARE JUST
INITIATING ON LAUNCHING THIS
YEAR WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
US OUT THE COSTS ENABLE US TO
INSTALL MORE THAN WE.
WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO.
SO ARE THE COSTS SO HIGH AND
CONNECTIONS GOV YEARS EARLIER
QUESTION BECAUSE
HAVE YOU WRITTEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I DON'T RECALLS BEING
THAT HIGH. WHO INSTALLED ARE THE
CHARGING STATIONS FRANKLY AS YOU
INSTALL MORE EACH LOCATION THOSE
COSTS DOES DIP DOWN THE
TECHNOLOGY IS STILL IN ITS EARLY
STAGES BUT WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT WHEN WE HAVE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THE
BECAUSE MUCH LOWER THAN THAT
IT'S JUST THAT? AT EACH LOCATION
THERE'S NOT CONSISTENTLY TWENTY
SPOTS SIR YOU KNOW THIRTY SPOTS
SOME OF THEM HAVE THREE OR FOUR
BUT THEY STILL HAVE A VERY
STRONG NEED BECAUSE THEY HAVE
STRANDED FLEET VEHICLES SO WE.
ON THOSE SITUATIONS COSTS ARE
HIGHER AND ON THE SITUATIONS
WHERE WE HAVE MORE EACH SITE THE
COSTS ARE MUCH LOWER THEIR
AVERAGE YOU YOU PROJECT REACH
FACILITY I MEAN FOR FIVE OR.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT I THINK AT
CDC ARE THEY HAVE LARGE NUMBERS
AND AND THERE WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE THE ECONOMIES
OF SCALE. DMV'S SAME THING C. H.
P. THOSE ARE DEPARTMENTS WHERE
WORK AND HAVE.
A LARGE NUMBER OF INSTALLATIONS
AND BE ABLE TO KEEP COSTS REALLY
LOW PER INSTALLATION.
OTHER PLACES.
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB OR FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHERE THERE'S A SMALLER
NUMBER THAN THE COST WILL BE
HIGHER.
.
GOING UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT ANY
WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
A GLENN CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT. ON
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE LIST OF
OPEN.
SO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM SHE
NEVER THREE. LEGISLATION.
SHARE COOPER.
WE HAVE.
THREE REQUESTS TITLE
LEGISLATION FLASHERS GOVERNOR.
THE FIRST IS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT TWO TWO AUTHORED BY
SOMEONE CABALLERO THIS MEASURE
CREATE A FIVE PERCENT BID
PREFERENCE FOR CALIFORNIA GROWN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
DO YOU DDS IS REQUESTING THREE
UNDERNEATH THOUSAND SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND INTO PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF AB EIGHT TO TWO.
THE MY YOU KNOW MY OFFICE KEEP
OF OTHER ALL THREE OF THEM WITH
ELECTIONS ON THE BULK SECOND
MEASURES SP SIX OH FIVE BUT
CENTER GALGIANI THIS MEASURE
CREATES A NEW SMALL BUSINESS
CERTIFICATION SPECIFICALLY FOR
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS.
DS IS REQUESTING THREE AND
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND IN S. R.
F. AUTHORITY AND NOT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TO OWNERS
OF THE FOUR THOUSAND AND TWENTY
IN NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY. A AND
ON GOING FIRST.
THE START UP COSTS THE PROGRAM
INTO PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
DEVELOP ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM.
THE THIRD IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIX TWO BY MISTER BONTA THIS
MEASURE REQUIRES DDS TO
ESTABLISH THE MAXIMUM ACCEPTABLE
BLOOMING GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL FOR FOUR CATEGORIES OF
BUILDING MATERIALS BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN.
MEASURE THAT PROHIBITS BUILDING
MATERIALS THAT EXCEED THE
MAXIMUM ACCEPTABLE AVERAGE FROM
BEING USED IN STATE PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS THIS INCLUDES UC AND
CSU PROJECTS AS WELL. DDS IS
REQUESTING SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND
SERVICE REVOLVING FUND FUNDING
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONGOING. INCLUDING
ONE PERMANENT POSITION TO
ESTABLISH THE THRESHOLD TO
MANAGE ITS NEW PROGRAM. A AND
THAT TODAY I AM HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THESE.
LL. NO CONCERNS FINANCE.
YOU WISH TO SPEAK FOR THE
PUBLIC.
A CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR DVS
WAS THE PROCESS FOR UPDATING THE
STATE CONTRACT MANY OF PURSUANT
AB TWO SIX TWO.
YES I THINK THE QUESTION ROLES
AROUND THE THE ONE TIME FUNDING
REQUESTS.
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THAT FIRST YEAR AND
IT'S.
YOU HAD LESS TO DO WITH THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED UPDATING US A
CONTRACT EMMANUEL AND MORE WITH
THE NEWNESS OF THIS PROGRAM SO.
THE BILL REQUIRES US TO LOOK AT
SOMETHING CALLED ENVIRONMENTAL
PRODUCT DECLARATION WHICH
COMPANIES GONE CONTRACT FOR TO
ASSESS A THESE MATERIALS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS ON.
WHEN THEY'RE BEING PRODUCED I'D
HAVE RELATIVELY NEW INDUSTRY AND
THERE'S NO SINGLE CLEARINGHOUSE
FOR THESE WHEN THEY'RE DEVELOPED
SO THERE'S A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH AND EXPERTISE THAT'S
KIND OF OUTSIDE OF AND ANYONE IN
THE STATE ROOM. AT THIS POINT SO
THAT DOLLARS REQUESTING THE
FIRST YEARS A CONTRACT OUT FOR
THE SERVICES AND EXPERTISE WE
NEED TO GATHER ALL THE
INFORMATION AND DATA SO THAT WE
CAN SEND APPROPRIATE THRESHOLD.
OKAY.
RECOGNITION SOLIS ITEM OPEN
SLOWLY OPENED.
NEXT ITEM MUSICIAN EVER FOR
MERCURY CLEANERS SITE MONITOR.
SO IF YOU FOR DTS IS REQUESTING
AN ANNUAL APPROPRIATION OF FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND TO
CONTINUE WITH SITE MONITORING AT
THE MERCURY A CLEANER SITE. OVER
LAST YEAR WE'VE WORKED ON
EXTENSIVE REMEDIATION EFFORT
SITE. A PRELIMINARY.
REMEDIATION IS NOW COMPLETE OR
MORE OF ME INTO A PHASE OF SITE
MONITORING TO ENSURE THAT THAT
ARE WITH THOSE REMEDIATION
EFFORTS WERE INDEED SUCCESSFUL.
THIS REQUEST IS CONTINUE THE
SITE MONITORING ACTIVITIES
THROUGH GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE FISCAL YEARS
ST MUTTERING WILL NEED TO
CONTINUE TO OCCUR. AS REQUIRED
BY THE REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD AND WITH ME THAT I
HAVE.
JIM MARTIN HIS OUR ASSET
MANAGEMENT BRANCH CHIEF WHO'S
AVAILABLE ANSWERING QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM OKAY LL NOT CONCERNS
FINANCE.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS I
THINK WE TOUR TWO YEARS AGO
THAT'S CORRECT WHEN THE PAST
MACLEAR SITE MONITORING BCP. WAS
BLOCKED THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS WITH REQUESTS FOR
ONGOING FUNDING. THIS ESTIMATE.
MISSUS MADE THE NEED FOR ANY
REQUEST AND UPDATES ON SITE
MONITORING.
THAT'S THIS THIS REQUEST IS JUST
FOR ONGOING MONITORING FOR THE
FORTY FOUR WELLS AND. FOR.
ANY REMEDIATION THAT MAY COME
STILL NEEDED BASED OFF A
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD.
SO SALUTE DOES ELIMINATE MAYBE
NEED FOR AND THE REQUESTED
UPDATES ON SITE MONITORING. THE
THERE WILL BE CONTINUING NEEDS
FOR.
SITE MONITORING PROBABLY FOR
QUITE SOMETIME DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE WATER BOARD SENDS.
DO S. PLAN TO BUILD ONE SLIGHTLY
FUTURE IT'LL ORDER.
UP.
BATES STOP CONVERSATIONS WITH.
THIS SUMMER WITH THE WATER
BOTTLE CAN HAVE A BETTER FEEL
FOR WHAT. THAT LEVEL OF THE
REMEDIATION HAS SPENT YOU NOW
THERE'S THERE'S NOT THEN
SPECIFIC RIGHT NOW BUT YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE SURROUNDING AREAS
YOU KNOW WE WOULD MIGHT WORK
WITH KEETA. BUT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAVEN'T.
PER BEEN PURSUING. PURSUED
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL WAITING TO
SEE WHAT THE REMEDIATION WILL
LOOK LIKE.
BUT YOU'RE JUST PAID ANSWERED BY
THE SUMMER AND SUMMERS GAS WHERE
WERE WE PLAN ON MEETING WITH THE
WATER BOARD THIS JULY AND. YOU
KNOW BASED OFF A YEAR FROM WHEN
WE DID THE ELECTRICAL RESISTANCE
HEATING TRAINING.
HEAT RESISTANCE REMEDIATION AND
UP GIVE US ABOUT A YEAR. TO
ANALYZE THE DATA AND AND ALL
WILL WILL SEE WORK ON WHERE WE
STAND. JET LOOK FOR THE HEARING
WHICH YOUR FINDINGS ARE
ABSOLUTELY AVOID OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT.
CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
SADDAM'S COULD BE HELD OPEN SO
THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM SHE NEVER FIVE.
MODIFICATION OF FUNDING
STRUCTURE FOR THE CONTRACTED
FISCAL SERVICES.
GET YOUR COOPER.
ON THIS ITEM DID YES REQUESTING
OVERALL BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION BEGINNING
IN THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO FULLY
RECOVER COSTS
AND PROVIDE FISCAL SERVICES TO
DEPARTMENT CLIENTS. ADDITIONAL
DTS IS REQUESTING TWO THINGS
THIS PIECE PETER FIRST THE
MODIFICATION OF THE FUNDING
STRUCTURE PROGRAM WHICH RESULT
ABOUT A THREE MILLION PRODUCTION
SERVICE REVOLVING FUND AUTHORITY
AN INCREASE OF THREE POINT ONE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY. AN INCREASE OF TWO
POINT THREE MILLION INSERT A
CENTRAL SERVICES COST RECOVERY
FUND.
STAFF REPORT PRETTY CLEARLY
LAYS OUT THE DYNAMICS OF FUNDING
MODIFICATIONS AND.
DDS WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
DEPARTMENTS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
TO DETERMINE AGREE ON THE
WORKLOAD NEEDS THE BUSINESS UNIT
THE TOTAL COSTS.
OIL. NEW CONCERNS FINANCE.
HOW THE PROGRAM ASSESSMENTS
AFFECT THE AGENCIES?
SO I'M HAPPY TAKE THIS QUESTION
LET'S FINANCE WOULD LIKE TO.
JOHN FITZPATRICK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS.
.
THE PRIMARY MOTIVATION FOR THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO MAKE IT TOO EASY
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON THE
VARIOUS ENTITIES SO THAT WHEN
THE COSTS.
FOR CFS ACTIVITIES CHANGE A YEAR
OVER YEAR.
IT DOESN'T DIRECTLY IMPACT YOUR
BUDGETS THE FUNDING TO PAY FOR
THESE ACTIVITIES WILL COME
DIRECTLY FROM THE FUNDS THROUGH
THE PRO RATA. PRO RATA PROCESS.
WILL COST INCREASE OR DECREASE
USING THESE METHODS.
HE'S.
SETTING IT UP THIS WAY WON'T
IMPACT THE COSTS IT'S.
MECHANISM FOR PAYING FOR THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH DOING
THE.
BUDGETING ACCOUNTING SERVICES
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS SOURCE COST
NEUTRAL.
CORRECT.
THE PRO RATA THAT THIS SHIFT TO
USING PRO RATA IS BECAUSE IT IS
NOT A EACH
AFFECTING THE COST WOULD BE JUST
DOESN'T ANNUAL BASIS AS WE
DETERMINE OUR COST RECOVER. AND
IT BECOMES A RATE THAT WE CHARGE
CLIENT DEPARTMENTS.
IN ADDITION TO CHANGING THE
METHOD OF BILLING.
FOR EACH ENTITY THE OVERALL
EFFORT ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PRO
PROPOSAL.
.
UNCOVERED.
THE DEPARTMENT NOT FULLY
RECOVERING FOR THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SEA PROGRAM.
SO THERE IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IN THIS PROPOSAL FOR OVERALLS
CFS SERVICES BUT NOT AS A RESULT
OF USING PRO RATA AND I KNOW.
THAT'S GETTING INTO THE
TECHNICAL WEEDS OF.
HOW THE VARIOUS ENTITIES ARE
BILLED BUT THE PRO RATA PORTION
IN ANOTHER SELF WHAT IMPACT
COSTS DOWNSTREAM?
THANK YOU.
GOING UP AND UP PUBLIC COMMENT
ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.
I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
REQUISITIONS THE LIST ITEM OPEN
THE WORLD OPEN.
NEXT ITEM ISSUE NUMBER SIX
FINISH TECHNOLOGY STAFF
AUGMENTATION.
CHECK OVER A FEW
.
MORE MISTER CHAIRMAN JACK ABOUT
WILL SMITH'S DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CALLED BEVERAGE
CONTROL WITH ME IS READY DEEMS.
CHIEF OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES.
FIRST ITEM.
IS I REQUEST FOR INFORMATION
TAG TECHNOLOGY STAFF
AUGMENTATION REQUESTING EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND TWO ENGINES
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING THIS WILL PRIMARILY FUN
THREE PROJECTS.
ONE IS.
FURTHERANCE OF PROJECT FOR
ONLINE SERVICES
ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS NOMINEE
APPLICATION RENTALS.
THE SECOND IS FOR RE DESIGN OF
OUR EXTERNAL AND INTERNAL WEB
SITES.
AND THE THIRD IS TO CREATE AN
ONLINE SYSTEM FOR PRICE POSTING
FOR BEER DISTRIBUTORS
WHICH IS CURRENTLY A PAPER
PROCESS.
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
LL. NO CONCERNS FINANCE.
BUT YOU COULD FINANCE WE SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL.
KBC ORDEAL F. DISCUSS A. B.
C.'S FUND BALANCE.
SO THE AB CAESAR. WROTE HER
RELATIVELY HIGHER FUND BALANCE
IN THE PAST AND BUT THIS IS
MAINTAINED BY SIGNIFICANT
SMALLER SAVINGS FROM THEIR
INVESTIGATOR CLASSIFICATION. A
MORE RECENTLY WAGE INCREASES
HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED FOR THE
INVESTIGATORS AND SO YOU'RE
SEEING ADAM ARE SEEING DIMINISH
OUR SAVINGS AT THE SAME TIME. AN
INCREASE IN THE RATE OF DECREASE
FUND BALANCE.
AS RESPONSE ABC HAS RECENTLY
ADJUSTED.
THERE RATES ARMED UP HERS A
ACCORDING TO CPI PER STATUTE ARM
AND WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE FEE
PROPOSAL FOR. TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY.
AND SO HOW THIS FEE PROPOSES
ALSO A PART OF A LARGER MISSION
BASED REVIEW FOR THE ABC.
THIS PROCESS IS GOING TO INCLUDE
OUTREACH TO STAKEHOLDERS AND
LEGISLATURE'S WELL.
SO WE'RE IN PROCESS OF
ADDRESSING THIS.
OKAY.
IT IS AS A SIDE NOTE I KNOW WE
DID WE TALK ABOUT THE.
SALARY ISSUES LAST YEAR I WAS
BEEN CORRECTED WHO NEVER HEARD
BACK IF BIG ISSUE WITH.
RECRUITING RETENTION WHEN AWAY
SO IF IT'S A PLANNED LEAD TO.
HEAR BACK I CAN GIVE YOU TWENTY
SECONDS ON NETWORK.
OUR VACANCY RATE FOR AGENTS IS
DOWN BELOW FIVE PERCENT SOBRE
WERE AT A NORMAL ATTRITION RATE
THAT'S PRIMARILY BECAUSE WE'RE
CLOSE TO THE DOJ ALSO BEACON
WHICH WAS OUR PRIMARY SOURCE OF
POACHING AND OUR SECOND ISSUE.
WAS THAT WE DID WE USE TO DO
ONCE YOUR RECRUITMENT AND WE NOW
DEAR RECRUITMENT THREE TIMES
HEARING THAT HAS. CREATED MUCH
MORE INTERESTING CONTINUITY IN
THE HIRING PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
A PUBLIC URBAN COMES TO THE
PUBLIC.
HE WILL PLOP CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT. A REPETITION DEL THIS
ITEM OPEN THANK YOU.
THAT'S OUR MISSION OVER SEVEN.
FISCAL INFORMATION SECURITY
POLICY OPERATION.
OKAY SO WE'RE REQUESTING FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX THOUSAND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND I'M
GOING.
THIS IS GOING TO IN THE IN THE
FIRST YEAR IT'S GOING TO BE
PRIMARILY SOME ONE TIME I'M
FISCAL UPGRADES FOR SECURITY
SYSTEMS.
PLUS TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ON GOING AND THE SECOND
IS.
IT IS.
OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND I'M
GOING. FOR VARIOUS SOME
UPGRADES.
PREP PROBABLY PRIMARILY THROUGH
SUBSCRIPTION BASED SERVICES TO
INCREASE IT SECURITY.
ON A VARIETY OF FRONTS.
WELL ON YOUR MOBILE DEVICES
PRIMARILY HANDHELD PHONES ARE IS
THAT IT.
YES.
LL NO CONCERNS FINANCE.
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
GOOD REGULATIONS DOLLARS ITEM
OPEN WALDRON OPEN.
NEXT ITEM IS THE SHE NUMBER
EIGHT. THE RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
SERVICE TRAINING PROGRAM CASE SO
THIS IS A PRODUCT OF.
AB TWELVE TWENTY ONE.
WHICH CAME LAUNCH ON JANUARY
FIRST WERE REQUESTING FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING IS ESSENTIALLY
A PROGRAM BY WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO REQUIRE THAT ALL SERVERS.
I'M SERVING ALCOHOL ON UP FOR
CONSUMPTION ON SITE UNDERGO A
TRAINING COURSE IN RESPONSIBLE
NUMBER BETWEEN PROBABLY FOR AN
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
WHAT THIS THESE FUNDS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO DO IS TO DO
STAKEHOLDER OUT REACH?
I'M CREATE REGULATIONS TO BOMB
CRATER CURRICULUM AND OTHERWISE
MONITOR THE PROGRAM AND ALLOW US
TO AUTHORIZE TRAINING PROVIDERS
AND THEN TO MONITOR THOSE
TRAINING PROVIDERS I'M ON GOING
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATUTE.
GIVE ACOSTA FOR THE FIRST TWO
YEARS ARE ABOUT TWO OR THOUSAND
DOLLARS HIGHER. THE COSTS
INCLUDING THE APPROPRIATION
ANALYSIS.
EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE IN COST
SURE THAT THERE IT LIKE MANY
THINGS IN OUR ACT
VERY TECHNICAL EXPLANATION OF
THE ACT.
BUT BUT THE WAY THE ACT READ.
UNTIL THE VERY END OF THE BILL
SEASON ARM IT WAS A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING AND THEY ARE NOW CSUS
WAS THE WAY IT WAS WRITTEN IT
WAS ONLY FIVE THOUSAND SERVERS.
BECAUSE IT IT KEYED ON NON
RETAIL SERVICE WHICH IS VERY
SMALL ONCE IT WAS CORRECTED TO
INCLUDE.
FOR RETAILERS ITSELF THE NUMBERS
OF SERVERS WENT FROM FIVE
THOUSAND TO FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
NOW WILL IT BE ONLINE AT ALL
THIS IS ALL IN PERSON IT'S IT'S
IT CAN BE ONLINE OR IN PERSON WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE MAJORITY OF
IT WILL BE ONLINE JUST GIVEN
ECONOMICS.
OKAY THAT'S GREAT.
ALLEN WRITTEN THIS IS A LIST OF
OPEN SERENA WILL OPEN.
UNLESS I MISS YOU WERE NINE
SANTA ANA BUILDING RELOCATION.
I'M SO WE'RE REQUESTING TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AN ON GOING.
SOME OF THOSE AMOUNTS ARE
UNCERTAIN BECAUSE WE DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE LEASE DEALS IN
PLACE BUT ESSENTIALLY THIS IS A
PRODUCT OF THE NEED FOR US AND
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO MOVE OUT
OF THE SANTA ANA STATE BUILDING.
INTO OTHER SPACE THAT'LL BE
LEAST.
LL.
SO WE HAVE NO SPECIFIC CONCERNS
AT THIS POINT THE GOP SEE RENDER
SENATE NOW COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
MOVE.
SO OUR INITIAL CONCERNS I THINK
ARE ADDRESSED BY THAT AND WE
WOULD NOTE AS THE DEPARTMENT
MENTIONED.
THAT THE RENTAL RATES ARE STILL
BEING SOLIDIFIED AND SO IT'S
POSSIBLE THEY'LL BE NEED TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT ON THE ON THE FINAL
DOLLAR VALUE. THANK YOU FINANCE.
WE WOULD ALSO SUPPORT OUR ANY
ACTION BY THE SUB COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE FUNDING BASED ON THE
FINAL NEGOTIATED RATE.
INCOMES FOR THE PUBLIC.
OKAY RECOMMENDATIONS THE LOWEST
LEVEL POSSIBLE THAT OPEN.
NEXT I WILL BE ISSUE NUMBER TEN.
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
IMPEACHING BUDGETS MANAGER. AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT OUR FIRST REQUEST.
IS TO ADJUST THE DEPARTMENT OF.
THE DEPARTMENT'S INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY OFFICES WORK LOAD
GROWTH AND RISK MITIGATION
INITIATIVE.
THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND SIX
HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
AND FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND ON GOING TO BEGIN
ELIMINATING BACKLOGS AND TO FILL
CRITICAL RESOURCE AND SKILL GAPS
IN THE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
OFFICE.
THESE RESOURCES WILL ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO INCREASE THE
CAPACITY AND COMPETENCY OF THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY OFFICE TO
A LEVEL WHERE IT CAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
MAINTAIN SUPPORT.
AND SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS CRITICAL TO
SURVEYING CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
IN ITS REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. OF
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS
THIS REQUEST WILL BE FUNDED BY A
THE STATE CORPORATIONS FUND
LOCAL AGENCIES DEPOSIT SECURITY
FUND FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FUND
AND CREDIT UNION FUND. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND HERE
WITH ME IS WHEN YOU HAVE ROTH OF
OUR IN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
OFFICE WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. OIL NO
CONCERNS FINANCE WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL.
NICHOLAS IN THE PUBLIC.
HER CONDITION THE ITEM OPEN
SLOWLY OPEN.
NEXT LEVEL OF ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN STUDENT LOAN SERVICING.
OUR SECOND REQUEST IS.
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND AND FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND SIX
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND ONGOING
TO IMPLEMENT THE STUDENT LOAN
SERVICING ACTS.
THE REQUESTED POSITIONS ARE TO
SENIOR FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
EXAMINERS TO PERFORM
EXAMINATIONS ON STUDENT LOAN
SERVICING LICENSEES AS REQUIRED
BY CHAPTER EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
STATUTES OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
TO ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYST AND TO STAFF
SERVICES ANALYSTS TO HANDLE
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. THIS
REQUEST WILL BE FUNDED BY THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FIND.
AND HERE WITH ME AS MULLIN
DUDLEY ASSISTANT DEPUTY OVER THE
STUDENT LOAN SERVICING PROGRAM
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
YOU LL KNOW CONCERNS FINANCE WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
INCOMES IN THE PUBLIC.
GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS DELUDE
SADDAM OPEN SWELLED OPEN
THINKING.
NEXT ITEM FISHING NUMBER TWELVE.
ENTERPRISE DATA STRATEGY
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS RICHARD GO
AHEAD I'M THE DIRECTOR OF.
HEALTH PLAN PART IN HUMAN
RESOURCES AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT OUR ITEMS TO TODAY.
IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU KNOW THE
START WITH THE FIRST ITEM.
THIS IS A REQUEST THEIR WE'RE
REQUESTING POSSESS THREE
POSITIONS AND ABOUT HALF PLANNED
DOLLARS AND FUNDING.
TO CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS FOR
ENTERPRISE DATA STRATEGY AROUND
HUMAN RESOURCES DATA IS YOU.
PROBABLY KNOW WHAT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND STATE IT SYSTEMS.
HUMAN RESOURCES DATA IS IS
HIGHLY SIDELOAD SOME OF IT IS
HELD THAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE SOME OF ITS
HELD. A COLLEAGUES ARE SOME OF
IT IS DUPLICATED BETWEEN THE TWO
ENTITIES FOR VARIOUS PURPOSES.
AND SO.
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF OR TWO
YEARS AGO WE STARTED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. THAT SORT
OF COME TOGETHER AND FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN RATIONALIZE THIS
GOING FORWARD.
AND WE'VE CREATED A.
AND ENTERPRISE ARCHITECTURE.
TO.
HOUSE.
APPLICATIONS A SUPPORT HUMAN
RESOURCES WORK IN VARIOUS FORMS.
THE CONCEPT OF AN EMPLOYEE COR
RECORD SO WE CAN START HAVING
ONE. RECORD FOR AN EMPLOYEE THE
FALLS IN THROUGHOUT THEIR
CAREER.
AS THEY MOVE.
IN VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND.
VARIOUS LEVELS THROUGHOUT THEIR
CAREER.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FUNCTION A SENSE THAT A HIDE AND
WERE SORT AT THE POINT NOW WHERE
OPERATIONALIZE IN THIS THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGIES.
BUILT THE THE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM WE.
JUST COMPLETED PROCUREMENTS FOR
THE FIRST APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
GONNA SIT NOT PLATFORM WHICH ARE
GOING TO BE A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS TO HELP OUR
DEPARTMENTS TRACTOR TRAINING
NEEDS AND THAT. THEIR PLAY
TRAINING RECORDS AND WE HAVE A A
SORT OF A A ROAD MAP WHAT WE
INTEND TO PUT ADDITIONAL
SERVICES BASED ON THE PARTIES
ABOUT APARTMENTS IN THAT IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
ORGANISTS ARE TO BE THAT. OWNERS
OF.
MOST THE EMPLOYEE DATA IN THAT
AND SO WE'RE ASKING FOR A
PROJECT MANAGER.
A DATA ARCHITECT
AND.
AND A BUSINESS REQUIREMENTS
PERSON TO HELP A STAFF THAT
EFFORT NOTS WHAT THE SONG SOME
OF THE CHANGE AGENCIES THAT
ELECTRONIC FILE BILL ACCESS
LATERAL FOLLOW THEM THAT'LL THAT
HOW THAT WORKED TECHNICALLY.
WELL THAT THERE THERE'S TWO
ASPECTS OF IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
SYSTEM YOU'RE ACCESSING IT
THROUGH WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
TRAINING RECORDS FOR EXAMPLE
ONCE WE HAVE A COMMON EMPLOYEE
IDENTIFICATION AND IT'S IN A.
SHARED DATABASE ENVIRONMENT
THEN AS THEY MOVE THAT
TRANSACTION WILL MOVE WITH THEM
THERE AND THEIR TRAINING HISTORY
BE AVAILABLE.
BOTH MEN EMPLOYEE LOOKING IT UP
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT TRACKING EMPLOYEES
TRAIN.
SO WHAT ABOUT IT DOUBLE THE
TRAINING FOLLOWED BELDA THE
PERSONNEL FILE. WHAT THAT THAT
DOES OUR FUTURE APPLICATIONS WE
INTEND TO BUILD INTO THIS
ENVIRONMENT AND EXPAND THE USE
OF IT THE FIRST ONE? OUT OF THE
GATE IS A LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM BUT THERE'S THERE'S PENT
UP DEMAND AND DEPARTMENTS FOR
TIME ATTENDANCE.
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IS
LOOKING AT THAT THE NEXT PHASE
I'M A PAYROLL SYSTEM ALL THOSE
APPLICATIONS WE ANTICIPATE BEING
IN A SHARED ENVIRONMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ELLIOTT.
ANNETTE SCHROEDER ELLIOTT
NOTHING TO ADD FINANCE.
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL ANY
QUESTIONS IN THE PUBLIC.
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS THIS ITEM
OPEN SO HOLD OPEN.
WE WANT OUR NEXT ITEM.
ISSUE THIRTEEN MERIT SERVICE
SEES ME MERIT SYSTEM SERVICES
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
THIS ITEM.
.
IT IS THAT INTERESTING PROGRAM
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE PROBABLY
DON'T KNOW THE STATE OPERATES
AND AND I IN SHORT THEM COUNTIES
THE RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
VARIOUS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING I'M
MONEY MANDATES THAT THEY HAVE
THEY A CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM IN
PLACE FOR THE EMPLOYEES THAT
WORK IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND SO.
ARE CURRENTLY THE STATE HAS THAT
SORT OF A TWO TIER OVERSIGHT
ROLE OVER THIS FUNCTION ROUGHLY
HALF THE COUNTIES WILL MORE THAN
HALF THE COUNTIES.
HAVE BEEN DELEGATED TO OPERATE
THEIR OWN.
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM AND THE
STATE'S ROLE IS.
IS I I DON'T KNOW OVERSIGHT OF
THAT ANA ON A ROTATING BASIS AND
IN. OTHER MANY COUNTIES MOSTLY
SMALLER ONES ACTUALLY.
LOOKED TO US TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES
BOTH SERVICES ARE CURRENTLY DONE
THROUGH A THIRD PARTY CONTRACT
WITH COOPER PERSONAL SERVICES.
AND I WITH THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT AND SOME RESOURCES A FEW
YEARS AGO WE STARTED LOOKING AT
THE FEASIBILITY OF TRANSITIONING
THIS TO.
COLLEGE OUR EMPLOYEES TO STATE
EMPLOYEES.
AND WE'RE AT THAT POINT THAT'S
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
THERE'S OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD
WE WANNA A PHASE OUT THE
CONTRACT WORK DONE BY CPS AND IN
SOURCES TO STATE EMPLOYEES ME
WITNESSES.
AND SYSTEM OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION ACQUIREMENT LISTS
THAT THE WORK OF THE STATE IS
DONE BY STATE EMPLOYEES THIS IS.
WORKED A CLEARLY CAN BE DONE
WITH STUDIED IT FOR A COUPLE
YEARS. I WOULD PUT FORWARD A
THOUGHTFUL TRANSITION PLAN OVER
OF ROLLING THREE YEAR BASIS.
AND OUR CONTRACTOR IS.
OUR VENDOR IS AWARE OF THIS
WERE CURRENTLY NEGOTIATING A NEW
CONTRACT BECAUSE A CRACK
CONTRACT EXPIRES ON OR ABOUT
JULY ONE.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS PROPOSAL
WE'RE NEGOTIATING A CONTRACT
THAT SORT A STATUS QUO WITH THEM
CONTAINED A BROAD THE SERVICES
AND ONE THAT ANTICIPATES THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZING THIS
PROPOSAL SO WE'RE PREPARED TO
GO.
CONTINUE THE WAY THAT THE THAT
THE DISCUSSION THE LEGISLATURE
STILL.
YOU SAY YOUR CONSIDERATIONS
REQUEST THANK YOU LL.
I THINK THAT FINANCE.
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
INCOMES THE PUBLIC.
OKAY RECOMMENDATIONS ALSO HOLD
THE SADDAM OPEN SO HOLD OPEN.
AND THEIR SIAMESE ISSUE
FOURTEEN.
RETIREE HEALTH CENSUS DATA
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SO
THIS ITEM.
IS A RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD
ITEM WE.
.
PEOPLE THINK OF THE HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS NOW THE BENEFITS.
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES RETIREES IS
BEING PROVIDED BY CALPERS AND
AND THAT'S TRUE FOR HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS.
BUT CALLIE TAR IS THE ENTITY
THAT PROVIDES OUR.
THE VISION AND DENTAL BENEFITS
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES THE DENTAL
BENEFITS FOR RETIREES AND WE
HAVE A WHOLE.
ROSTER OF VOLUNTARY BENEFIT
PROGRAMS GROUP LEGAL SERVICES
LONG TERM DISABILITY THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
THAT WE ALSO ADMINISTER ON
BEHALF OF STATE EMPLOYEES AND
OUR RETIREES.
RECENTLY.
IN THE.
NOT TOO DISTANT PAST.
.
CALPERS USED TO EXCHANGE
INFORMATION WITH THE SUN AND THE
BASIS OF BASIC GIVE US CONTACT
AFFIRMATION FOR ALL THE STATE
RETIREES.
SO THAT WE COULD NOTIFY THEM OF
UPCOMING OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIODS
BENEFIT CHANGES THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
HELENA THAT BEEN GOING ON FOR.
DECADES.
I'D I'D LIKE TO HAVE EXACT DATE
BUT IT WAS A LOT SENATE PRACTICE
AND HOW.
.
SOMEBODY RAISED A QUESTION ABOUT
A CALPERS LOOKED INTO IT AND
DETERMINED THAT AND THAT WAS A
CLEAR THEY HAD.
SPLIT THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO GET
THAT INFORMATION TO US.
WHEAT WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
BILL THAT TO KEEP IN CONTACT
WITH OUR RETIREES CALPERS IS THE
SYSTEM OF RECORD FOR CONTACTING
THEM THEY KEEP INFORMATION UP TO
DATE A CALPERS BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDE THEIR BENEFIT.
YOU KNOW THAT THEIR MONTHLY
RETIREMENT WANT TO THEM.
AND SO WHAT THIS RESCUE FORCE
TO GIVE US THE AUTHORITY OR GIVE
CALPERS AUTHORITY TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH US SO THAT IT'S
ACCURATE. AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE TO.
NOTIFY THEM OF BENEFIT BENEFIT
CHANGES ARE OPTIONS THAT THEY
MAY BE INTERESTED
IT WAS AMAZING THAT WELL FOR SO
LONG AND PROBABLY SOME LAWYER
LOOKED AT AND SAID NOPE CAN DO
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
THEM.
LL.
FINANCE.
SUPPORT THIS.
INCOMES IN THE PUBLIC.
OKAY WELL THIS ITEM OPEN ALSO.
THANK YOU.
IN OUR LAST ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN.
STATE PERSONAL BOARD.
NO.
MR SERVICES WORKLOAD.
HELLO HELLO.
AND SO THE STATE PERSONAL BOARD
IS REQUESTING FIVE POSITIONS.
THREE ANALYSTS.
ONE BUSINESS SERVICES OFFICER
AND ONE STAFF SERVICES MANAGER
TO PERFORM IO FUNCTIONS.
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND COME FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND REIMBURSEMENTS
AND A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
CENTRAL SERVICE COST RECOVERY.
PHILADELPHIA.
WITH NO.
FINANCE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
HEY WE WISH NICHOLAS PUBLIC. I
WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OTHER CONDITIONS THE WHOLE THIS
ITEM OPEN.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING.
HAVE A GOOD DAY